hello reject nation of Greg Alva I'm
John Humphrey I'm not used to filming
with my hair out like this we're gonna
watch today from a varial 10 seconds
songs there's actually a time in like
2015 where you're supposed to do some
type of cross collab thingy yeah yeah
that didn't actually pan out but how you
doing bud good to see you again
you're gonna hit him up again revitalize
that flame yeah hopefully he just
catches this video with Bohemian
Rhapsody coming out this weekend
Bohemian Rhapsody performed in 42 styles
people I'm excited to do this you see
over at her patreon we do Q&A a TV show
reactions John does a lot of music video
covers but one of our top reward tiers
whatever video you request we must
definitely do put up on the youtubes
and today comes from vigilance watchful
Gregory Bullock let's get into this
I miss you sexy with that go Kate
[Applause]
he's gonna get good
and wait for me
[Music]
go across channel
let's go into the other forty two styles
one second at a time yeah can't wait for
the M&M yes
[Applause]
ha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's so cool it's so cool
I envy this challenge move it vocal
inflections yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
[Music]
it's a triptych and
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
ah
Oh
wow you really done a lot more editing
with your pity goose whoa now oh wow
javi correct
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dude you got to get Muse in here oh yeah
oh yeah
Queen inspired bangs
[Music]
[Music]
address
[Music]
absolutely
check out the Russian TV
[Music]
[Music]
I love this
haha right back into routine hey let's
see one of the Dream Eater ago
[Music]
full circle
[Applause]
[Music]
crooked frets
[Music]
beautiful yeah I have a big announcement
I have merchandise oh I finally have
merchandise I got my face on shirts and
I have my face on hoodies and I even
have my face on my own mug oh by the way
I made sure to use every single mug so
whoever orders a mug you have a
complimentary smudge of my lips you know
I was always embarrassed by the thought
of having merchandise you know my face
and a shirt on a hoodie and a mug but
then I realized what the hell
still the merch link is in the
description check that out I also want
to thank you all for watching believe me
in rhapsody in 42 styles I never almost
thought this day would it never came you
know it was a big task and I finally
decided to to really do it and just
disappear for a little while to get it
done and I want to thank you all for
requesting the song and I guess I was
just in the mood because the movies
coming out soon make sense
I can't wait to see I want to thank Iraq
for being in this video as always and
for those of you who don't know me and
Iraq started a band called Riptide and
we're putting out our debut album our EP
in the next month in November awesome
just what you all know some of you have
been asking about updates for that
project and that's what's happening in
November we're putting out another
single and then that's gonna be
following the album release and all that
with that being said I want to thank all
of my patrons for making this video
possible and videos oh is possible if
you want to support me on patreon the
link is in the description below thank
you again for watching I got that coming
yeah yeah got more stuff on the way a
lot of patrons made to paint over yet
I'll see you soon dude
it's been a while since I seen whatever
there wasn't there stained one I haven't
seen one of your videos in a while and
your editing style I don't know if this
is a consistent thing or you
specifically did it for this one I loved
all the new touches that I'm not seeing
it like when the artist names appears
you have a photo of them in case you
forgot what they look like or who they
are you have a photo of them to reappear
and also like that moment where you had
that weird like they were going around
the dad style yeah yeah I had the
different like Skrillex and Death Grips
and a few other things breaking in like
it really happened succession rewind
fast-forward is like things were
overlapping one another like brilliantly
done especially for this song that adds
to the effect of it when this just makes
me wonder that much more of like this is
they always seem very polished and very
mapped out but this seems like you
actually probably had to like produce
your own like very manic backing records
yeah yeah I'm always fascinated at the
construction of these because like you
really do seem to just get down the
nuances of each different singer you go
for it's like crazy to hear you Channel
Hold'em especially guys like you know it
like Bowie or Frank Sinatra or any of
those and then like the mouth guitars oh
lovely yeah creative and I love all the
like different instrumental breaks too
with like the facial expressions adding
a little comedy the bow definitely I
mean I'm wondering how many because you
usually have one master frame that seems
to be one take and then you have these
two other shots I like two little
squares so I'm wondering like retakes
are you doing per sequence per moment of
what you're doing and do you just do
that one section to like cuz there are
times where you do like only just a few
like 10 seconds that's sometimes you do
less than 10 seconds per artists but are
you recording more than that before
those moments and you like to do it a
whole version then cutting around you
mix it first and do the one take like
what are you doing exactly yeah it's
such an interesting methodical process
that maybe we learn about on your page
crayons yeah might just have to pledge
to find out I know what it is did you
get sexier look you got sexier I think
the go tease them more chiseled I mean
the locks are flowing and curling like
beautiful you know ropes of dark
yeah I'm you know I wouldn't mind
wearing your face on my shirt I wear my
my face in your crotch if you need a lip
smudge man dude oh man I'm on more stuff
in that mug to drink out of you know I'm
saying maybe because it's been that long
sexy videos I'm making those kind of
comments a little BK party you know what
I'm saying Burger King Burger King party
yeah yeah your work seems to really
shine through here because of the fact
that I could actually listen to this and
with the way how Bohemian Rhapsody the
song that song alone already changes up
so many different styles it has a lot of
different parts and components and it
oscillates between a lot of different
different rhythms yeah so what I'm
hearing this and even though you're
shifting through drastically different
styles all the way from something like
you know Frank about on the Four Seasons
is System of a Down yeah it still kind
of has a flow maybe because this is the
specific song you're covering a lot of
times when you know I watch ten second
songs it's always cool to see like good
hey the different style
yeah here I could listen to it it would
seem like one fluid song and I think
that's what was the most impressive to
me about this like it's been a while
since I've seen one of your videos and
it seems like not only with your editing
style but also with the main core of it
all of the song yeah and just knowing
really fine-tuned everything over there
it's crazy how after all these years
you're still one of the best channels
I've ever existed yeah man one just the
knowledge of where to put a tone shifter
or a tempo shift or something like that
so that it's not horribly jarring like
that stuff I imagine just you get better
and better and better at over time to do
so many styles - it's like I'm used to
some of the lighter ones but this is
like thick yeah imagine that you like if
you want to you just make any kind of
music now the only off part about this
was when Eric was there the green screen
was weird because [ __ ] Anthony yeah man
yeah hey he's doing quit being lazy with
your videos and do something okay that
should be a professional because it was
so obvious that he was green-screen
the blur there that's very frustrating
and a waste of my time school ghost
t-shirt though honestly this whole like
eight-minute video I was very much
distracted because of that and just took
me out if I was a commentator I would
only comment about that and nothing
about your song yeah I was distracted
the whole time even before he came in I
was just like I know there's gonna be
some green screens in here that son of a
[ __ ] son of a B but I hope you're doing
well and stay sexy and I like your cat
we should have your cat meet my two cats
and watch them get it on in a battle
royale
yeah dude and that can be the collab
that finally happens yeah Canada in 40
different boys I can video game alright
guys well hey you guys should definitely
subscribe to ten second songs if you
haven't already
Gregory Buller thank you for the request
buddy Gregory Bullock is someone I
talked to pretty much five days a week
randomly on patreon
I love the hell out of this guy he
actually shared with me a poem recently
that is a very vulnerable piece I'm
hoping he starts putting out his
material out there because he's one hell
of a writer he's a musical talent as
well
he said he's working on started up a
channel I think it's more movie related
content but really keep a look out for
this guy when he starts releasing his
musical stuff because he is one heavily
musically inclined artist and he such
such a joy such radiant positivity all
the time love you Gregory and that was
to me yeah alright Bullock alright guys
well you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
hey why don't you go ahead check us on
patreon q and A's TV show reactions and
of course music video coverage would
love to have you and you and you become
a patron eject today or tomorrow